[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
رياض نبدا
ازمه ثقه بين واشنطن
والكرملين لا يستبعد التجسس الامريكيه على
الخارجيه الايرانيات تكشف عن توجه فريق
فني الى السعوديه للوقوف على اعاده فتح
السفر
الحكومه الكويتيه تؤدي القسمه امام ولي
العهد والنواف يتعهد بالعمل مع جميع الاطف
في الرابعه
انطلاق الحمله الوطنيه الثالثه للعمل
الخيري في السعوديات تبرعات
بالمليارات وملايين المستفيدين
[موسيقى]
والرابعه توثق بعض العادات الرمضانيه في
جزيره تاروت شرقيه السعوديه
جمعات المقاهي جزء من التقاليد
تبدا بهذا الخبر العاجل حيث كشفت قناته سي
ان ان عن ترشح الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
رسميا الانتخابات الرئاسه القادمه 202
سابق عن غموض حول الوقت الذي سيعلن فيه
بايدن بدء حملته الانتخابيه بشكل رسمي في
وقت ابهرت فيه استطلاعته رايا امريكيه عدم
رغبه الديمقراطيين في ترشح بايدن لولايه
ثانيه
ازمه ثقه تعيشها الولايات المتحده مع
حلفائها خصوصا اوكرانيا بعد تسريبات وثائق
البنتاجون الرئاسات الروسيه ذكرت ان
تسريبات وثائق البنتاجون لم تحمل اي جديد
فيما يخص التجسس الولايات المتحده على
حلفائها اضاف المتحدث باسم الكرملين موسكو
لا تستبعد ان واشنطن تتجسس بالفعل على
الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه كانت اوكرانيا
احد عناوينها الرئيسيه التسريبات المصنفه
سريه للغايه وهي الابرز منذ عقد قد تؤدي
الى تعقيد العلاقه بين امريكا وحلفائها
وتحديدا كييف التي لجات الى تغيير خططها
العسكريه في اول تحرك بعد التسريبات
تفاصيل التي تم الكشف عنها في 50 صفحه
اظهرت كيف تتجسس الولايات المتحده في
الواقع على الاصدقاء والاعداء على حد سواء
اسرار مروعه تم الكشف عنها من بينها توصل
المخابرات الامريكيه الى مرتزق روسي مزعوم
يحاول الحصول على اسلحه من دوله عضو
بالناتو لاستخدام هذا ضد اوكرانيا الوثائق
المسربه توضح ايضا كيف تمكنت الولايات
المتحده من اختراق عمق الجيش الروسي ما
يمكنها بالفعل من تحذير اوكرانيا مسبقا
اذا ارادت ذلك ففي فبراير من هذا العام
وبحسب الوثائق المسربه كانت الولايات
المتحده على علم بان الجيش الروسي يعد
لهجوم على منشات الطاقه والجسور في
اوكرانيا لكنها التزمت الصمتحي لذلك
الوثائق كشفت ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني اس 300 من الحقبه السوفيتيه
ستنفذ بحلول مايو الامر الذي اغضب
مسؤوليكييف الذين سعوا لاخفاء نقاط قوتهم
وضعفهم عن الكرملين
وقد طلب رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو
بضمانات من قبل روسيا بانها ستحمي بلاده
في حال التعرضها للهجوم افادى عبر تطبيق
تيليجرام بانه التقى وزير الدفاع الروسي
في داعيا اياه للدفاع عن اراضي بيلاروسيا
كما تدافع روسيا عن اراضيها
اكدت وزاره الخارجات الايرانيه ان وفدا
فنيا سيتوجه الى السعوديه خلال ايام لبحث
اعاده فتح السفاره في الرياض وكانت وكاله
تسنيم ذكرت ان الوفد قد يتوجه الى الرياض
غدا الثلاثاء للوقوف على استعدادات اعاده
فتح السفاره عقب الاتفاق على استئناف
العلاقات السياسيه واعاده فتح سفارتي
البلدين وزاره وفد فني سعودي ايران السبت
الماضي لمناقشه اليات فتح السفاره في
طهران
والقنصليه في مشهد
فيديوهاتنا من الرياض عضو مجلس الشورى
واستاد العلوم السياسيه الدكتور ابراهيم
النحاس حياك الله دكتور دكتور يبدو ان
التجهيزات لاعاده فتح السفارتين
تتسارع على قدم وساق امام يمكن لمسات
الاخيره لاعاده فتح السفرتين في البلدين
تقييمك دكتور في متابعتك لهذا الحراك فيما
يتعلق بالجهد الدبلوماسي
لفتح السفرتين انا ذاهب بالاتجاهات
الايجابيه نحو تحقيق السلام الذي تنشده
دول المنطقه والمعتدله على الاقل تقدير
وايضا الشعوب الذين
اعانوا كثيرا من مساله الله استقلال في
المنطقه وغياب الامن وزعزعه المجتمعات مثل
هذه الزيارات مثل هذه اللقاءات تجعلنا في
على الاقل تقدير نطمح لان تشهد المرحله
القادمه العوده الطبيعيه للعلاقات بين
الدول وفقا للقانون الدولي وفقا لما هو
معتاد عليه في العلاقات الدوليه بين الدول
المحبه التي امن والمحبه للسلم والمحبه
الاستقرار
ايضا للتكاتف يدا بيد نحو البناء والتنميه
والتطلعات التي تذهب اليها حقيقه الشعوب
التي تعمل الرفاهيه ولا تعمل غير ذلك ان
تعمل السلام ولا تعمل الصراع والحرب وان
نقف يدا واحده ايضا في مواجهه الجماعات
والتنظيمات الخارجه عن القانون الداعمه
للتطرف هذا هو المامول وهذا هو الذي يقرا
من مثل هذه الزيارات الايجابيه وايضا نقطه
غايه في الاهميه هنا وانه النظم السياسيه
في المنطقه المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
راسها داعمه وراغبه ودافعه للسلام ودافعا
للتنميه ودافعه للمحبه والامن وهذا هو
الذي تدفع به باتجاه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبهذه اليد الجميله اللي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
تاخذ معها دول المنطقه جميعها والان
الجانب الايراني يذهب بمثل هذه الاتجاهات
ولذلك مثل هذه الزيارات ومثل هذه الخطوه
الايجابيه في اعاده فتح السفارات بين
الدولتين ونعلم بانه السفارات
والدبلوماسيه هي الخطوه الاولى نحو السلام
والبناء وبالتالي كيف يمكن تصور طبيعه
العلاقه في المرحله القادمه بين الرياض
والظهران الى فتره القطيعه والاشكاليه
التي حصلت فيها نعم هذا التسارع الايجابي
الذي حدث منذ توقيع المصالحه في بكين وحتى
الزياره الاخيره والاقامه الخارجيه تجعلنا
نتفاءل كثيرا بان نحن ذاهبون باتجاهات
الغايه في الايجابيه نحو نسيان الماضي
ومعالجه الاخطاء التي وقعت في الماضي
ومعالجه الاسباب التي ادت الى القطيعه الى
مرحله كبيره جدا
والابتعاد عن المسببات والاسباب التي جعلت
المملكه تقطع علاقاتها مع ايران وجعلت
ايران تذهب باتجاهات سلبيه في مراحل
الماضيه هذا هو الذي يؤمل عليه في المرحله
المستقبليه وهذا هو الذي يبنى عليه في
ايضا في المستقبليه لماذا قطعت العلاقات
ولماذا عادت مثل هذه العلاقات الان لماذا
ابتعدنا عن بعضنا في مرحله معينه ولماذا
نقترب الان من لمرحله معينه لماذا اقفلت
السفاره في مرحله معينه ولماذا تعد هذه
السفاره هذه الاسئله هي التي سوف تجاوب
عليها هذه المرحله لاننا ذاهبون
بالاتجاهات الايجابيه التسارع الايراني
حقيقه ايضا ايجابي جدا نطمح ان يكون هذا
العمل ليس فقط في الحراك الدبلوماسي وانما
ايضا على ارض الواقع بان نكون جميعنا في
دول المنطقه يد واحده متكاتفين لبناء
السلام والتنميه شعوب المنطقه حقيقه
استاءت كثيره معينه خاصه في الدول الغير
مستقره الشعب في ايران الشعب في العراق
الشعب في سوريا وفي اليمن وفي لبنان
يريدوا الرفاه يريد التنميه يريد
الاستقلال يريدوا ولذلك هناك تعويل كبير
من الايرانيين على الدوري السعودي قادم من
ناحيه التبادل التجاري استثماري ايضا ذكر
ذلك على لسان اكثر من مسؤول ايراني وحتى
اعتقد سعودي لكن الى اي مدى نعم عدم
التوصل حتى الان الى الاتفاق نووي وما
يجره ذلك من عقوبات على ايران يمكن ان تحد
من التوجه البلدين الاستثمار المشترك
بينهما خاصه السعوديه نحو هذه نقطه غايه
في الاهميه لانه نعلم بانه اتفاق النووي
وما اتبعه من عقوبات دوليه يفرض على الدول
في التعامل مع ايران ياخذ هذا الجانب في
عين الاعتبار بان العقوبات الدوليه يجب ان
تكون ايضا لا تضعنا في صدام ايضا مع
المجتمع الدولي الا انه ما نامل عليه
حقيقه في مثل هذا الاتفاق ان التصرف
الايراني الايجابي دعمها للسلامه ابتعاده
عن التطرف والارهاب ابتعد عن دعم الجماعات
الارهابيه لعله يدفع المجتمع الدولي
بالتفكير في انهاء هذه الازمه في التوقيع
على اتفاقيه النوويه على الاقل تقدير
بقبول ايران ايضا ان كانت محبه للسلام
بقبول المقررات الدوليه وهذا الذي تطمح له
المركبه السعوديه بان لا تنتشر الاسلحه
الدم الشامل في المنطقه وانت تبتعد ايران
عن التصرفات السلبيه ان ذهبت ايران بمثل
هذه الاتشات الايجابيه اعت ان قوه المملكه
الدوليه وعلاقاتها الايجابيه مع دول
المجتمع الدولي تستطيع اخراج ايران منه
مثل هذه الازمه وايضا نبدا بعلاقات تجاريه
اقتصاديه تستفيد منها دول المنطقه
بالتنسيق مع الامم المتحده والتنسيق مع
الدول الكبرى في المجتمع الدولي التي فرضت
العقوبات على ايران ولذلك نحن جميعنا
نستفيد ان ذهبنا بالاتجاهات البناءه
والمسالمه بالتزامن ايضا هناك تحرك سريع
ايضا نشاهده فيما يتعلق بازمه اليمن ملف
اليمني من اهم الملفات صحيح في المنطقه
وهو الملف ربما الاول الذي يعول عليه في
تطبيق هذا الاتفاق او المضيق ودوما في
بالامس كان هناك وفد سعودي عماني ايضا
برئاسه السفير السعودي في اليمن
ومباحثه اجرت مع الحوثيين دكتور اريد ان
اقرا عليك كما ذكرته واشنطن تايم على سبيل
المثال تقول لازمه في اليمن مستعصيه على
الحل رغم ذوبان الجليد بين ايران
دكتور الى اي مدى يمكن بالفعل تعويل على
هكذا تحركات في في في معالجه او في احتواء
سلوك ايران في اليمن الحوثيين ايضا خلال
المرحله القادمه بعد هذه التحركات من
الطرفين انا اعطيها نسبه عاليه جدا في
تغير السلوك الان في اليمن لانه اليمنيين
جماعه الحوثي تحديدا ادركت بانه الذهاب
باتجاهات السلبيه لن يفيدها ولن يوصلها
الى التحكم بالدوله اليمنيه او حتى يسيطر
على المخدرات الشعب اليمني ادركوا بعد
فتره طويله جدا وخاصه ان الموكب السعوديه
منذ العام 2011 وحتى الان هي تدفع باتجاه
المصالحه اليمنيه اليمنيه الان
الحوثيين ذهبوا باتجاه جلوس جميع الفرقاء
على الطاوله واحده الاستماع الى ابناء
اليمن الاخرين وبالتالي سوف يكون هناك
دستور قد يكون يمني جديد بالت يفصل اليه
حكم دوله اليمنيه بما يرضي جميع الاطراف
اليمنيه وليس فقط طرفا واحدا يستاثر
بالسلطه التعويل على مثل هذا بالسعوديه
الايراني اعتقد انه غايه في الاهميه
وايجابي جدا سوف يكون لانه ايضا ايران
ادركت بان ممارسه السلوك السلبي في اليمن
اظرها اكثر مما يفيدها بشكل كبير جدا
والحوثيين ادركوا ايضا ذلك يضاف انه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه جاهزه تماما
دائما ان كان هناك سلام في اليمن فسوف
تكون جاهزه لدعم هذا السلام بالجانب
الدبلوماسي الجانب السياسي الجانب المالي
الجانب التجاري الجانب التمويلي والاغاثي
وبالتالي سوف يستفيد جميع ابناء اليمن
الصوره الايجابيه التي شاهدناها
لسفير المملكه في ايضا بحضور الوفد
العماني غايه في الايجابيه وتعطي بانه
الجانب الحوثي ايضا يريد الذهاب من كل هذه
الصوره هل يمكن ان تذهب بالفعل لما قال
بانه هناك اتفاق سيرى النور قبل نهايه شهر
رمضان نعم وانا ادعم مثل هذا الاتجاه لسبب
انه المصالحه في اليمن تدعم من جميع اطراف
المجتمع الدولي وليس فقط السعوديه لانه
جميع الجانب الاوروبي الجانب الامريكي
كلها دائما كلها داعمه ومؤيدين للموقف
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودافعين له في
الاتجاهات الايجابيه ولذلك سوف يكون
النجاح في اليمن من مصلحه ابناء اليمن ومن
مصلحه المنطقه بالتالي واضح شكرا جزيلا لك
السياسيه الدكتور ابراهيم النحاس شكرا
دكتور شكرا لكم
اهلا بكم من جديد اوضحت الامانه العمل
لهيئه كبار العلماء في السعوديه ان الدعوه
الى انشاء مذهب فقهي اسلامي جديد تفتقد
الموضوعيه والواقعيه وبينت ان الفقه
الاسلاميه بمذاهبه الفقهيه المعتبره
واجتهاداته المتنوعه يستجيب لجميع مطالب
الحياه الحديثه ويوفق بين حاجاتها وشريعه
الاسلاميه وهو ما تبرهن عليه الهيئات
العلميه والمجامع الفقهيه التي تمارس
الاجتهاد الجماعي
الكويت استقبل ولي العهد الشيخ مشعل لاحمد
الجابر الصباح في قصر بيان رئيس مجلس
الوزراء الشيخ احمد النواف وزراء الحكومه
الجديده لاداء اليمين الدستوريه بمناسبه
تعيينهم واكد ولي العهد خلال الاستقبال ان
المصالح العليا للبلاد مسؤوليه الجميع من
قياده وحكومه ومجلس امه وجهتها هكذا الشيخ
احمد النواف ان الحكومه الجديده ستقوم
بالعمل والتعاون مع جميع يعطيها في
المجتمع الكويتي لتحقيق مستقبل افضل
ضم الينا من الكويت المخلل السياسيين محمد
السبتي سيد محمد حياك الله هل في هذا
المشهد اي جديد هل هي حكومه حل لازمه ام
حل مجلس
الحقيقه لا جديد
الاجراءات التي تمت من تشكيل الحكومه وقسم
هؤلاء الوزراء امام اسمه ولي العهد ليس هو
الا استحقاقا دستوريا
واجراءات بروتوكوليه يعلم الجميع ان
الحكومه استقرت منذ فتره طويله وتم تكليف
رئيس الوزراء بتشكيل حكومه جديده ولم يتم
هذا التشكيل حتى شكلت البارحه وحلف هؤلاء
وفق هذه الاجراءات والاستحقاقات الدستوريه
لكن لكل مواقب ان يعلم ان اليقين مستقر في
نفوس جميع الاطياف السياسيه بما فيهم سمو
رئيس الوزراء بما فيهم رئيس مجلس الامه
انه لا تعاون بين الطرفين بل اكثر من ذلك
هناك تصريحات واضحه جدا من كتل نيابيه
انهم لن يتعاونوا مع رئاسه مجلس الامه
الجديده ولا مع يعني الوزراء الجدد
وبالتالي
قرار حل جديد لمجلس الامه كما اظن يقينا
ولن يخرج عن هذا السياق ابدا كيف ستكون
للخطوات للوصول الى هذه النتيجه
بلا شك ان هناك خلاف وخلاف شديد جدا بين
الدستوريين وفقهاء الدستور في هذه المرحله
اعني بذلك هل يجوز
للحكومه ان ترفع مرسوم الحل قبل ان تستكمل
يعني اجراءات تشكيلها بالكامل بما في ذلك
القسم امام مجلس الامه
كثير من الفقهاء يرون ان الحكومه يجب ان
تقوم يعني استكمال اجراءات تشكيلها وهذا
يستلزم ان تحضر في جلسه مجلس الامه وان
يقسم رئيس الوزراء والوزراء كذلك امام
مجلس الامه ثم بعد ذلك يكون لهم قد يكون
لهم يعني رفض مرسوم حلم المجلس الامه الا
ان الواضح ان هذا لن يتم
واظن ان كل اجراء سوف يتخذ من الحكومه
الحاليه سوف يكون مطعم كذلك امام المحكمه
الدستوريه في القادم من الايام بلا شك وهو
يعني تكرار لسيناريو سبق ان الحدث عوده
الى نفس المربع دوران حول نفس النقطه لا
يمكن التعويل على اي نتيجه
او توقع اي نتيجه بتكرار نفس الادوات
والوسائل
للاسف بدنا يعني بدنا نخجل من تكرار
كلامنا كنا في الثمانينات كان هناك عنوانا
في الصحافه الكويتيه يحذرون الكويتيين من
لبننت لبنان من ان نسير كما سار النهج في
الاحزاب اللبنانيه ثم في بدايه التسعينات
اصطلح الكويتيون في الصحافه على ما يسمى
بصومله الدول يعني عدم تكرار
النموذج الصومالي بدنا نخشى ان يقول الناس
ابتعدوا عن يعني كوتته هذه المجتمعات عدم
تكرار هذه التجربه السيئه التي نمارسها
لممارسه يعني هذه الديمقراطيه والعمليه
الانتخابيه بطريقه خاطئه للاسف من جميع
الاط
نبقى في ذات المشهد في ذات المربع وكل
خطوه تتخذ امامها كذلك
مئات الطرق من الطعن امام المحكمه
الدستوريه
والتكالب والتسارع في وهل ستظل الكويت تصل
على هذه الطريقه على هذا النهج دائما يعني
بدون اي نتيجه بدون اي لا في حاله واحده
اذا اعترفنا بهذا الخطا اذا تجرعنا مر
الاعتراف بالخطا ما زال كل المجتمع بما
فيها تلك الاطراف الحكوميه او الكتل
السياسيه يعني يستكبرون على انفسهم
الاعتراف بهذا الخطا الذي مارسناه خلال
يعني مده طويله
وحتى لا نجرع على تعديل بعض البنود في هذا
الخطا ما لم نعترف بهذا الخطا يضم كل عاقل
لست انا فقط كل عاقل يظن اننا لن نخرج من
هذا المازق سيدي الفاضل لماذا يعني نستشهد
باقوال غيرنا قبل يومين فقط عقد رئيس
الامه مؤتمرا صحفيا وصرح النبقاء سمو رئيس
الوزراء خطر على الكويت في كل يوم يبقى
سمو رئيس الوزراء خطر على الكويت ونحن لا
نقر هذا طبعا ولا نوافقه لكن هذا
يستطيع كل عاقل ان يستغرب من خلال المشهد
المشهد واضح جدا نعم اقول ها وبكل مرار
سوف نبقى في ذات المربع سوف تبقى ذات
الطعون سوف نمارس ذات العمليات الانتخابيه
ثم تجرى طعون انتخابيه على ذات النقاشات
التي ناقشناها نحن وناقشها اباؤنا وهم قبل
الاجداد نبقى في ذات حتى
نعترف بهذا الخطا ونتجرع مراره هذا
الاعتراف ثم نذهب الى الطريق الصرع للاسف
شكرا جزيلا لك من الكويت المحل للسياسي
محمد السبتي
في المدينه المنوره وبعد تشغيل المسجد
النبوي بكامل طاقته الاستيعابيه في موسم
رمضان شاهد القطاع السياحي والفندقي نسب
اشغال مرتفعه تصل الى 90% ما جعل مشغل
القطاع الفندقي يعملون على رفع التجهيزات
ومستويات التشغيل للتعامل مع الاعداد
المليونيه التي تشهدها المدينه المنوره
[موسيقى]
بعد سماح الجهات المختصه في السعوديه
باداء مناسك العمره والصلاه في المسجد
النبوي بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود
يشهد قطاع الفنادق في المدينه المنوره
اقبالا ملحوظا ونسب اشغال مرتفعه وصلت الى
90% مع دخول شهر رمضان السنه هذه لقينا في
اقبال اكثر من العام الماضي تقريبا في
زياده تقريبا من 10 الى 15% في اعداد
المعتمرين وفي الزوار كذلك يعني لقينا في
اقبال في عدد المصلين حسب الاحصائيات اللي
بترد من رئاسه شو الحرمين تتفاوت اسعار
الغرف الفندقيه مع قرب دخول العشر الاواخر
من شهر رمضان وبحسب قربها من المسجد
النبوي اتصلوا الى ثلاثه الاف ريال لليله
الواحده نظرا لزياده الطلب عدد الغرف
الفندقيه الموجوده في المدينه تقريبا 355
فندق تشكل تقريبا 65 الى 66 الف غرفه
فندقيه كانت نسبه الاشغال في هذا العام
تتجاوز التسعين الى 95% في بعض الايام
ولكن بمتوسط طول الشهر كانت 85% بالنسبه
للاسعار صار عليها زيادات تقريبا من عشرين
الى 30% خطوات ايجابيه اتخذتها الجهات
المهنيه بخدمه الضيوف الرحمن اسهمت في
زياده الاقبال على القدوم لتاديه المناسك
والعمره والشعائر في مقدمتها تاشيره
الزياره والسياحه المفتوحه طوال العام من
المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه
وفي المسجد الحرام تستعد رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين لتفعيل الخطه التنفيذيه الخاصه
بالعشر بالعشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان
استقبل الحرم المكي قرابه 17 مليون زائر
ومعتمر منذ بدايه شهر رمضان وتم افتتاح
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بخمسه ادوار
لتتسع لمليون شخص من الزوار والمعتمرين
خلال العشر الاواخر
الحرم المكي الشريف ايضا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه اسامه القاسم اهلا اسامه صف لنا
الصوره حيث
اهلا وسهلا خالد تحيه طيبه لك وللجميع
مشاهدين العربيه نعمل لكم الصوت والصور
اليوم من هنا من صحن المطاف بالحرم المكي
الشريف طبعا بالتاكيد استقبلت مكه المكرمه
اكثر من 17 مليون زائر ومعتمر خلال الايام
الماضيه هذه الخدمات ايضا التي نتحدث عنها
اليوم هي تقدم للزوار المعتمرين منذ بدايه
شهر رمضان المبارك على سبيل المثال سقيا
زمزم تم تقديم 25 مليون
لتر من سقيا زمزم للزوار والمعتمرين هناك
عدد كثير جدا من الخدمات تقدم اليوم لزوار
وقاصدين المسجد الحرام من الخدمات الرقميه
خدمات ايضا تقدم لي حتى الاطفال مثل
الاساور ايضا تصاريح الاعتكاف ايضا عدد من
الخدمات التي تقدم كالخدمات الانسانيه
والصحيه والعلاجيه الحديث اكثر عن هذه
التفاصيل يسعدني ان يكون معي الان استاذ
هاني حيدر وهو المتحدث الرسمي لرئاسه شون
الحرمين اهلا وسهلا فيك بدايه استاذ هاني
حدثني اليوم عن ما هي الخطه التشغيليه
التي تعملون عليها اليوم في شهر رمضان
المبارك وبالتحديد في العشر الاواخر حياك
الله استاذي العزيز الحمد لله رب العالمين
مضى حوالي 20 يوم من هذا الشهر الكريم
تكللت بالنجاح العميم شهدنا كثافه كبيره
من ضيوف الرحمن الذين وفدوا الى المسجد
الحرام من اداء العمره والصلاه وغيرها من
النسخ حرصه الرئاسه العامه للشؤون المسجد
الحرام والمسجد النبوي من خلال خطه
التشغيليه على توفير كافه الخدمات لتهيئه
البيئه الايمانيه الخاشعه المثاليه الصحيه
لقاصدي ضيوف الرحمن حارسنا في الرئاسه
العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام والمسجد
النبوي ان تكون خطتنا مرتكزه على عدد من
الاسس وعدد من المرتكزات اهمها محوريه
الضيف حرصنا في جميع الخدمات وجميع
البرامج جميع المبادرات التي نقدمها ان
تنال رضا الضيف الكريم ان تتوافد ان
تتوافق مع احتياجاته مع رغباته مع الاهداف
التي رسمها من اجل الوصول الى الحرمين
الشريفين ثانيها وهي الجوده والاتقان
وضعنا مؤشرات تشغيليه لجميع الخدمات وكل
موقع في كل خدمه مؤشرات تشغيليه دقيقه يتم
مراجعتها باستمرار من خلال كادر الرئاسه
الذين يحرصون حرصا شديدا على ان تكون
الخدمه في اعلى درجاتها وثالثها التكامل
والتنسيق مع كافه الجهات
يوجد جهات كثيره عامل في المسجد الحرام
على راسها طبعا وزاره الداخليه اماره
منطقه مكه المكرمه الجهات الامنيه الرئاسه
العامه وزاره الحج والعمره وغيرها من
الجهات التي تتكاتف وتتعاون من اجل تقديم
خدمه متميزه لضيوف الرحمن في الايام
القادمه باذن الله في العشره الاواخر جاءت
التوجيهات من قبل معالي الرئيس العام
الشيخ عبد الرحمن السديس تكثيف هذه الجهود
بتكثيف الخطه التشغيليه لذلك نحرص من خلال
عدد من المحاور اول هذه المحاور المحور
الخدمي
المحور الخدمي وهو اننا
نقوم بتعقيم وتطهير المسجد الحرام على
مدار الساعه يوجد لدينا اكثر من 4000 عامل
وعامله يعملون من خلال 70 فرقه ميدانيه
موزعه على مدار ال 24 ساعه للتاكد من
نظافه وتعقيم بيت الله الحرام يتم فرش على
مدار الساعه اكثر من 35 الف سجاده معقمه
يتم تعقيمه قبل الصلاه وبعد الصلاه يتم
تعقيم المسجد الحرام باكثر من
في كل غسله اكثر من 160 الف لتر من
المعقمات الصديقه للبيئه وثمانيه و1,600
لتر من المعطرات ايضا حرصنا على توزيع ما
يصل يوميا الى ربع مليون عبوه ماء زمزم
مبارك هذا فيما يتعلق بالجانب الخدمي فيما
يتعلق بالجانب الارشادي والجانب التوجيهي
حرصت الرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
والمسجد النبوي بالتعاون مع الامانه
العامه لهيئه كبار العلماء لاقامه العديد
من الحلقات حلقات الدروس العلميه
المحاضرات التوجيهيه وتواجد اكثر من 200
نقطه لاجابه السائلين بكم لغه ليست عشرين
لغه العام الماضي وصلت العام هذه السنه
الى 51 لغه بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى اعطني
استاذ هاني على المقاطع لكن اريد اسالك
ايضا سؤال اخر نحن اليوم نشهد الان امتلاء
صحن المطاف هل الخطه التشغيليه تختلف عن
خطه تشغيليه الاولى والثانيه بحكم ايضا
زياده الزهور المعتمرين المتوقعه خلال
العشر الاواخر امن الخطه ستشمل ايضا خدمات
اضافيه الخطه بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى كما
تفضلت هي هي منذ بدايه رمضان ونحن نعمل
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه الذي جاءت
التوجيهات الان به هو مزيد من الطاقه من
مزيد من الجهود مزيد من العمل
بالتعاون مع الجهات المختصه نحن ندرك ان
ضيوف الرحمن يقبلون بطبيعه الحال في العشر
الاواخر على المسجد الحرام لعدد من اسباب
اولها طبعا الرغبه في اغتنامي هذه الايام
الشريفه
فيها ليله القدر فيها ختم القران فيها
باذن الله صلاه التهجد الاعتكاف ايضا
ولدينا خطه متكامله فيما يتعلق بالاعتكاف
لعلنا نتحدث عنها وايضا فيما يتعلق
بالتكامل مع جميع القاصدين شكرا لك استاذ
هاني حيدر وانت المتحدث الرسمي اذا نتحدث
اليوم ورائي صح المطاف ممتلئ بالكامل كله
هذه الخدمات اليوم التي تقدم لزوار
وقاصدين المسجد الحرام بالتاكيد هي خدمات
كثيره وعديده سنكون ايضا ان شاء الله في
نشرات قادمه اتحدث عنها بشكل تفصيلي اكثر
وانتقالي اليكم شكرا جزيلا لك اسامه
القاسم مراسل العربيه من الحرم المكي
الشريف
نذهب الى شمال السعوديه تحديدا الى منفذ
الجديد تعرعر حيث يستمر توافد المعتمرين
العراقيين عبر المنفذ الذي سجل الدخول
اكثر من 200 الف معتمر منذ بدء موسم العمر
الكاميرا العربيه تواجدت هناك على الحدود
السعوديه العراقيه
[موسيقى]
يستمر توافد المعتمرين العراقيين عبر منفذ
جديده عرعر بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه
السعوديه وسط منظومه خدمات متكامله تقدم
من كافه الجهات الخدميه والامنيه السعوديه
نحن هنا في هذه الصاله نستقبل المعتمرين
العراقيين من خلال مشروع اماره منطقه
الحدود الشماليه لضيوف بيت الله الحرام
حيث تقدم للمعتمرين كافه الخدمات والضيافه
باشراف جمعيه التنميه الاهليه بعرعر
والمشاركه مع وزاره الحج في منفذ جديده
عرعر وجمعيه هديه الحاج والمعتمر وكذلك
الهلال الاحمر كانت التسهيلات بالطريق جدا
ممتازه من الجانب السعودي يعني بصراحه ما
توقعت هيك تكون التسهيلات الحمد لله قالت
لي ماما لا لا تروحين على
روح الجو قلت لها بشوف المعبر الجديد وما
شاء الله نفس حسن ظني
[تصفيق]
هذا المنفذ الذي سجل دخول اكثر من 200 الف
معتمر منذ بدء موسم العمره يستقبل
المعتمرين في شهر رمضان باماكن استقبال
مهيعه وبوجبات افطار متنوعه باشراف مباشر
من اماره المنطقه
اما دخلنا للمنطقه الحد السعودي من فضل
الله يعني شفنا الناس تلقونا بقلوبهم قبل
ايديهم
وشفنا تسهيلات جيده ونظافه وترتيب وما
شعرنا حتى لا بتعب لا تحضير امتعه ولا
بتنزيل ولا تصعيد وحتى بالختم وبس خلصنا
تلقون الشباب هنانا بضيافه فطور الله
يجازيهم الخير ويتقبل من عندهم ان شاء
الله
شكرا على الضيافه وان شاء الله التوفيق
للجميع
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء المعتمرون الذين يتوافدون من عده
محافظات من العراق ينطلقون في رحلتهم
الايمانيه وسط ترتيبات منظمه وطرق مهيئه
من الحدود السعوديه العراقيه
جزاعا ماصي العربيه
رابعه مستمره فيها بعد قله
انطلاق الحمله الوطنيه الثالثه للعمل
الخيري في السعوديه تبرعات بالمليارات
وملايين المستفيدين
ازمه ثقه بين واشنطن لا يستبعد التجسس
الامريكيه على
الخارجيه الانانيه تكشف عن توجه فريق الى
السعوديه للوقوف على اعاده فتح سفر
الحكومه الكويتيه تؤدي القسم امام ولي
العهد والنوافل تعهدوا بالعمل مع جميع الا
طلاق الحمله الوطنيه الثالثه للعمل الخيري
في السعوديه اعتبرعات بالمليارات وملايين
المستفيدين
[موسيقى]
ورابعه واثقوا بعض العادات الرمضانيه في
جزيره تاروت شرق السعوديه
جامعات المقاهي جزء من التقاليد
اهلا بكم في السعوديه تنطلق مساء اليوم
الحمله الوطنيه الثالثه للعمل الخيري خلال
شهر رمضان وذلك عبر منصه احسان لتمكين
وصول الدعم الى مستحقيه وبدرجه عاليه من
الكفاءه والموثوقيه
تنطلق مساء اليوم الحمله الوطنيه الثالثه
للعمل الخيري خلال شهر رمضان في السعوديه
وذلك بعد موافقه الملك سلمان على اطلاقها
تهدف الحمله الى تمكين وصول الدعم الى
مستحقيه وفق عمليات تبرع امنه وموثوقه عبر
التقنيات الرقميه من خلال منصه احسان كما
ستعمل الحمله على ضمان وصول شريحه كبيره
من المتبرعين الى مجالات خيريه متنوعه
بشكل سريع وسهل وخصصت الحمله مركز خدمه
لتلقي التبرعات
منصه احسان الخيريه اطلقت قبل اكثر من
عامين وتشرف عليها لجنه مكونه من 12 جهه
حكوميه في السعوديه فضلا عن لجنه شرعيه
لضبط عمليات التبرع التي ترد الى المنصه
اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات وثلاثمائه مليون
ريال جمعتها منصه احسان منذ اطلاقها وسط
اقبال من كافه الفئات على التبرع في
قطاعات تنمويه عده استفاد من تلك التبرعات
حتى الان ما يزيد على اربعه ملايين وثمائه
الف مستفيد رقم مرشح للارتفاع بشكل كبير
بعد نهايه الحمله الخيريه الثالثه
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض انضم الينا
الرئيس التنفيذي لمنصه احسان ابراهيم
الحسيني اهلا وسهلا بك خالد اليوم ان شاء
الله حتبدا الحمله باذن الله الحاديه عشر
مساء اعطينا يذكر في تفاصيل محيطه بهذه
الحلقه اليوم صدور الموافقه الكريمه من
مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين على اطلاق
الحمل الوطنيه لعمل الخير في نسختها
الثالثه امتداد الدعم الكبير من القياده
الرشيده للعمل الخيري وانطلاق هذه الحمله
يمتد الى نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك وهو
امتداد للدعم ونجاح نسختين الاولى
والثانيه من الحمله الوطنيه للعمل الخيري
في رمضان قبل سنتين حققنا اكثر من 700
مليون ريال في الحمله الاولى وفي الثانيه
800 مليون ريال ونستهدف ان شاء الله في
هذه الحمله تجاوز ارقام استثنائيه حققها
المنصه تبارك كيف اثرها هذه الحمله ومثل
هذه الحملات على العمل الانساني والخير في
السعودي نحن اليوم ونحن نفاخخ بوصول
المنصه الى ارقام استثنائيه مثل وصولها
الى ثلاثه مليون ايضا نفاخر اكثر بالاثر
الذي تحققه المنصه من وصولها الى المستفيد
والاسره الاشد احتياجا وتغطيه المنصه لعدد
من المجالات التعليميه والصحيه والتنمويه
ورعايتها عدد من المجالات التي تستهدف
دخول القطاع غير الربح في كافه مناطق
المملكه اليوم في منصه احسان مجموعه كبيره
من البرامج والخدمات سواء البرامج مع
الجمعيات الخيريه التي تجاوزت الف جمعيه
معتمده وهي مئه بالمئه وفق معايير الحوكمه
للمركز الوطني تنميه القطاع غير ربحي ووفق
معايير احسان وكذلك الخدمات المربوطه مع
الجهات بحكم ان اليوم منصه احسان تحت
رعايته الهيئه السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي سدايا فاستفادتها من البيانات
اوجد لها عدد من الخدمات التي ترتبط
بالعدل والسجون مثل فرجت وكذلك خدمه تيسرت
للتنفيذ القضائي وهذه الخدمات اليوم تتاكد
من البيانات وتعرض للمستفيدين او
المتبرعين المستفد المستفيد لاشد استحقاقا
ببيانات يتضح للمتبرع رغبه فيها اليوم
المنصه تسعى ويشاهد المتبرع نوع كبير من
الشفافيه يختار عمر المستفيد منطقته مجال
التبرع كم المتبقي وكم ذهب ويستطيع ايضا
الوصول الى تقارير معلومات مركبه ومعلومات
منشوره موثقه وهي مربوطه بالبيانات
الرسميه
احسان كيف انت شايفك بال الناس على هذه
المنصه يعني كمنصه للعمل الخيري انت تعرف
كان في جدل كثير حول حول العمل الخيري
بشكل عام والتبرعات التي تقدم يعني وخاصه
التبرعات الخارج او للداخل في اليوم
المنصه الى اي مدى كان هناك قبول تفاعل من
الناس معها يعني اليوم بحمد الله المنصه
تشهد اقبال كبير خصوصا في شهر رمضان من
المتبرعين اكثر من عشره مليون ريال يوميا
من المتبرعين الافراد يوميا من متبرع
بريال وريالين و10 ريالات تكفى ليومين
اكثر من 100 يتيم حالات متعلقه بالسجون
وايقاف الخدمات وغيرها من المشاريع ايضا
التنمويه والجدير بالذكر يعني اقامت منصه
احسان قبل شهر تقريبا حفل تكريم المحسنين
وتم عرض احدى المشاريع وهو مستشفى في
المدينه المنوره بجوار المسجد النبوي
بقيمه تجاوز 80 مليون ريال فاقبل
المتبرعين بشكل سريع وخلال نصف ساعه تم
تغطيه هذا المشروع فلا شكله يوم المنصه
تشهد اقبال كبير وخاصه في شهر الخير وفي
مواسم التبرعات وباذن الله خلال العشر
الاواخر
سيكون باذن الله للمتبرعين والمنسرين
الدعم الكبير للوصول الى ارقام كبيره في
المنصه
في خطط جديده للمنصه خلال فتره القادمه
خطوط عمل يعني باذن الله طبعا المنصه تسير
وفقه خطه واستراتيجيه معتمده من 12 جهه
حكوميه تشرف على المنصه وهذه الخطط تتمثل
في وجود برامج وخدمات للوصول الى كافه
المجالات واخر الخدمات التي اطلقت يمكن
خدمتين الخدمه الاولى العنايه بالمساجد
تستهدف رعايه المساجد واستقبال التبرعات
لها ومتابعه صيانتها والعنايه فيها بقرب
الشهر الكريم وخدمات ايضا تتعلق
بالعنايه بكبار المحسنين ورفع تقاريرهم
وعكس كذلك اثار هذه التبرعات بشكل
الالكتروني وماتمه اكثر التبرعات اللي
تجيكم في اي برنامج او اي نوع دكتور
بالارقام يعني طبعا اليوم 80% من التبرعات
هي من عشره ريال و20 ريال في المبالغ
البسيطه واكثر المجالات التي تستهدف اليوم
مجالات سقي الماء والايتام ورعايتها
المحتاجين هذه تستثمر بشكل كبير يليها
تفريج كره بالمساجين ومن كان عليهم حكم
بالسجن مع خدمه
الايتام وايضا السجون هذه اكبر خدمتين
اليوم عليها اقبال من المتبرعين واهتمام
ولذلك خصصت لها خدمات باحسان للعنايه
بهاتين الخدمتين الله يبارك فيكم ويجزاكم
خير شكرا جزيلا حسين ابراهيم الحسيني
رئيس تنفيذي لمنصه احسن شكرا لك
يستمتع اهالي جزيره تاروت في القطيف شرقيه
السعوديه بليالي شهر رمضان عبر المقاهي
العتيقه يرتادها الرجال ليلا للتسامر
وتبادل الاحاديث مع الاصدقاء الى جانب
تناول الاكلات الرمضانيه التقليديه عبد
الرحمن العصي
[موسيقى]
جزيره تاروت في القطيف تاريخ عريق وعادات
رمضانيه اصيله سنتعرف عليها عن كتب
حسن علي يعمل في محله الصغير هذا في اكثر
من اربعين سنه لا تزالوا ذكرياته حول شهر
رمضان حيه في وجدانه
والعالم تحصلونهم اكثر
للصباح
عندك الاول الحمام مباشر يجوا الناس
يتسبحوا
قصدك حمام
برشا والا حمام بالتركي
ليالي رمضان في هذا المقهى مختلفه بحسب
زبائنه فاهل تاروت يقصدونه للتسامر
والاستمتاع باجواء شهر رمضان الناس تحب
تجلس تروح على القهاويت تروح تتقهوى مثلا
تشرب شاهي زين في غير الدور الاستماع هم
يروحوا بعدوا يجلسوا هناك بس الاساس يعني
اجوا
الاماكن
القديمه هذه
المائده الرمضانيه في تاروت غنيه بالاكلات
الشعبيه التقليديه
هذه الاطواق السائده في رمضان السنه
المائده رمضان بتلاقي لقيمات موجود بتلاقي
السمبوسه موجود الهريس موجود هاي طبعا
هريسه
غير الاكلات هذه فيه الخبز مع الصالون
احنا نسميه تريد زين في المكانات ثانيه في
بعض المناطق المملكه يمكن يسمونها
الى اسماء ثانيه طبعا احنا نسميه تريد زين
مع الخبز والصالون ده اكلتي المفضله في
رمضان اول ما اقطر طبعا
واصلي على محمد وال محمد اتناول اللقيمات
اللي ما تناول جيمات
لو في مسوين هريس لازم اكل الهريسه
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من جزيره تاروت
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تعرضت طائره تابعه لشركه ريان
الايرلنديه الى حد حادث اثناء هبوطيه في
مطار دبلن وانكسرت عجله الهبوط الاماميه
دافع الطائره الى الانزلاق على المدرج
وتكوين مسار من الشرر لكن انتهى الحادث
دون تسجيل الاصابات
العناوين
ازمه ثقه بين واشنطن والكريم ليندا يستبعد
التجسس الامريكيه على زيلينسكي
الخارجيه الايرانيه تكشف عن توجه فريق فني
الى السعوديه للوقوف على اعاده فتح السفر
الحكومه الكويتيه تؤدي القسم امام ولي
العهد والنوافل تعاهدوا بالعمل مع جميع
الاطياف
انطلاق الحمله الوطنيه الثالثه للعمل
الخيري في السعوديه التبرعات بالمليارات
وملايين المستفيدين
[موسيقى]
والرابعه توثق بعض العادات الرمضانيه في
جزيره تاروت شرقيه السعوديه جماعات
والمقاهي جزء من التقاليد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات